- Okay. So I have to ask you,
did you ever ask him about
Batman? Cause I would have.
And I'm 39.
(everyone laughing)
- The first scene I filmed with him,
when they were like,
rearranging the cameras
and stuff like that,
I was sitting right
next to him in a chair.
So we were leaning forward
'cause the camera was like right here.
I was like, "So how's playing Batman?"
And he just told me all about it.
He said he had to wear this suit,
he was sweating and it was heavy.
(everyone laughing)
- [Kelly] Sound's not fun.
- [Robert] Don't give
away too many secrets.
(everyone laughing)
- It doesn't look like it breathes well.
I just thought it was so cool,
like to be able to sit by Batman.
I know my kid met Aquaman once,
and he like, it's like the
coolest thing he's ever done.
So I just thought
(laughing)
- Jason Momoa, he's just spectacular.
- But it's so funny how
your kids become like,
you seem like you do
well in this situation.
My kids, all of a sudden, like,
the loudest kids on the
planet will like, not speak.
- They clam up.
- And I'm like, what's
happening to you right now.
- No, no. I took my daughters
to meet Taylor Swift,
and they're...
What are you talk talking about?
We came all the way here
to meet Taylor Swift.
Say something.
- You look like a liar.
- I'm telling you they're
fans. You know what I mean.
(everyone laughing)
- You look like a liar. You're like,
I swear they know your songs.
(laughing)